looking back a decade later steins gate
remains as the trailblazer
in slow burner sci-fi and time travel
anime alike
following the story of okabe and his
fellow lab members through the flow of
time itself as they face an
unexpected enemy and more importantly
mend their own mistakes along the way
steins gate has rightfully cemented its
place among the anime greats
and steins gate is actually my favorite
anime mainly because i am so intrigued
by the hints
of deeper human meaning below the
surface level of anime and
media in general which there is endless
amounts of in steins gate
i've already made an entire video about
the depths of okabe's character in a
video a long time ago which despite my
embarrassment over its audio and editing
quality
the script and words behind it are
something that still stand true
and today i wanted to give my most
comprehensive analysis yet
not just of this show but on this
channel to date of
any anime starting with the adaptation
itself
how the anime was adapted from a visual
novel and why it works so well
to the story itself and the fundamental
parts of it like its humane appeal
that make it resonate across both
timelines and screens
to the viewers themselves we're breaking
down how steins gate set a new standard
for the dramatic
and thriller genres of anime for a
decade and
honestly likely more to come
[Music]
visual novels are often defined by the
countless paths you can take through the
story resulting in good and bad endings
or simply events you don't like
if you don't know the format it's
essentially just a text-based story that
is very very narrative driven
and adapting this into an anime can
understandably be very difficult
it requires transforming what is
basically an extensive compilation of
text boxes and still frames into a
concise and still
entertaining anime both visually and
plot-wise
the most notable adaptation of visual
novel like this to an anime apart from
stein's gate for reference
is probably the fate franchise but i
think the fate series adaptation suffers
from something that steins gate doesn't
excess similar to steins gate the fate
series is loaded with
lore and pieces of stories that have
been pieced together from various
storylines of the visual novel
there is so much sheer content in visual
novels
these two especially that studios have
to decide what parts of the fat to trim
what is essential and then somehow find
a way to coherently piece them together
it's far more difficult than just
adapting manga
of course i don't mean to degrade the
fate series here i love it and it's
always been one of my favorite anime
actually but the series definitely
needed the numerous adaptations and
separate anime story routes to
successfully cover
the entirety of the series which they've
done extremely well now that heaven's
feel has been covered by ufotable
but stein's gate did it in a single
season
and yes stein's gate zero and the movie
exist but the first series stand alone
still managed to capture a
relatively holistic adaptation of the
visual novel's vast
and multi-fasted original storyline it
doesn't suffer from the curse of excess
not because of some major studio
difference or logistical reason but
actually i think just because of how the
story itself works
because steins gates plot inherently
revolves around the central idea of
making and fixing your mistakes
entering new worlds and creating ripples
along the way exactly befitting
of the variable and very personalized
format of a visual novel
this is what makes the adaptation into
an anime so perfect
so meant to be is that we're actually
given contextually fitting reasons to
witness how one's actions
can cause unprecedented results and lets
us see
and possibly fix these changes just as
one would in the visual novel
time travel lets us see how different
choices can pan out without having to
stick to them
whereas the fate series is rigid in its
linear
non-time manipulating or alternate route
creating story
essentially steins gate successfully
transplanted the visual novel experience
into a completely
fluid and single anime but what is just
as important to note is that there are
many parts of the visual novel that it
didn't get to
if that's something you really want to
see the alternate routes that were
missed in the anime you should
definitely go check out the visual novel
because it's really great
but i digress credit has to be given to
the studio in choosing the right parts
of the story to make it feel
not like a too much to handle and be
just a mashup of different events and
instead like a very coherent tale that
despite jumping through different
timelines and sub-arcs
still follows one central idea the whole
time
and this is especially important with an
already confusing premise like
time travel and the reason that i'm
focusing on how
it was adapted from the visual novel is
that there are always complaints about
the adaptation of source material into
an anime
the top anime series of all time full
metal alchemist brotherhood had an
entire first anime series before
brotherhood
that suffered the fate and criticism of
pursuing an anime only route
it's straight away from the original
manga source material
attack on titan the next highest and
probably biggest show in the world right
now
is constantly critiqued for adaptations
of the manga into an anime whether it's
for animation reasons
pacing you name it anime always has
and always will suffer from the
discrepancies when transforming the
source material
as living up to the original creation of
something in any form of media is
difficult
and near impossible to get perfect
one of the biggest reasons that steins
gate avoided this is because
while it does give the anime watchers
what is essentially the best route
the perfect route you could take in the
visual novel
it also gives us a taste of each way
that it could have gone wrong
it offers tidbits and small insights
into the opportunities from the source
material that couldn't be fully
integrated
without feeling like simple fan service
because of the ease in
unraveling different timelines
in the top 10 anime on my anime list
only three of them
aren't shonen legend of the galactic
heroes
march comes in like a lion season 2 and
stein's gate
and though they vary extremely in the
kind of story they are
being a philosophical military anime a
touching slice of life
and time travel sci-fi respectfully the
one commonality that these three shows
share
is that they are very dialogue intensive
and character driven
without the extraneous addition of
flamboyant action scenes or villains or
high animation budgets
these stories revolve around the ripples
that a select group of characters have
yes on the world around them but most of
all on each other
and i think that stein's gate above all
does this the best
the cast of stein's gate is polar
opposite legend of the galactic heroes
which i just mentioned
which spans an innumerable cast of
characters across the galaxy that
sometimes feels cumbersome and not only
does steins gate deal with a small
close-knit group it even goes to the
liberty of labeling every single one of
them with a badge
and the reason i'm talking about this
the importance of side characters and
the small group that steins gate deals
with
is because i believe if there is one
thing that continues to push
anime to further heights it is the
appeal to humanity
this is the fundamental basis in all
animated works
any piece of art or literature where a
human connection
can't be depicted visually through an
actor or person
and must be interpreted instead and
though cartoons or anime certainly
stretch this line
it still applies art is only as deep as
humans make it
and i've already talked about the trials
of the main character okabe a lot before
check out that video if you want to but
today i feel like not enough is said
about
actually the others characters too the
side characters and the other lab
members
because what is special about stein's
gate again going back to the way the
plot is formatted
through each timeline and each dmail
were given a chance to see the biggest
flaw in each character
what they themselves would have changed
if they ever had the chance to
and that's beautiful ruka's insecurities
about her gender
moeka's crippling reliance on fb ferris
and her father
the show goes to great lengths to flesh
out these side characters and make them
feel like real people with
real regrets especially in an oftentimes
fantastical
and extreme story like steins gate which
is certainly a sci-fi anime above all
it needs to feel grounded to remain a
character and narrative driven story
like the visual novel intended to be
the series also deals with suicide a
very prominent issue in japan
and of course worldwide further
expanding on the show's appeal to very
real and human issues
only behind south korea japan has the
highest rate of suicide among developed
countries in the world
an issue that has only gotten more
significant as of late
and a lot of it stems from an issue that
is common among most east asian
countries like the aforementioned south
korea
which is the cultural weight of
expectations
and we see this in steins gate too moeka
commits suicide after fb
abandons her and she loses purpose in
her life
nowhere to go and no job to do suzuha
the first time she went back ended her
life after being unable to do the
mission she was tasked with
whether it was her own expectations or
those of others she felt overwhelmed by
it
mr brown also does this as he
understands that he's expendable for
cern
and that the job he's tasked with can be
given to anyone else after he fails
they're all very real personal
occurrences that can happen to anyone
losing a close friend or family member
being unable to do what you were tasked
with
being replaced the series crafts such
believable and realistic characters from
the watchers point of view
which is important for understanding
their humanity and their reasons for
acting as they do
it truly is the story of if a completely
normal friend group or group of people
were thrown into the journey of a
lifetime
and how they would deal with it how the
weight of expectations crushes
real people and this actually leads into
my last point and one of my favorite
themes in
all of stein's gate which is just being
satisfied with complacency
almost every story anime or not has a
final goal in mind
one that the main characters really have
to push for go through trials and
tribulations to reach
and finally get to the end knowing that
they're better than they were at the
beginning
it's just a simple story format
and what i love about steins gate is
that the goal they want to reach
is simply just to go back to how it was
after what okabe goes through in the
first half of the series climaxing in
the multiple deaths that mayuri has
and his decision to go back in time and
undo the d-males
the final goal of this series is simply
to go back to how everything started
which is unconventional to say the least
the top anime full metal alchemist
brotherhood actually does this in one of
its end goals
which is for the elric brothers to
simply get their bodies back
and repent for the mistakes they made as
kids
and the beauty about this kind of story
is that it always involves a mental
struggle
as the characters overcome their
internal regret with what they've done
and forego what used to be an overly
ambitious goal
instead for just simple happiness they
used to have
steins gate establishes a very
expectation driven society
as i was talking about earlier in
reference to suicide and
expectations whether it's from yourself
or others like family or friends
this is what causes people to want to
push further
to make something tangible out of their
efforts and we see just how this goes
wrong in stein's gate with the lab
members treading upon a realm that they
never should have
just like prometheus and the greek myths
okabe is punished for trying to give
god's powers to mankind
his ambition is punished and as we near
the end
all of the trials okabe goes through is
simply done
just to undo everything to go against
any gain that he and the group made in
order to return to that
blissful ignorance though i suppose it's
not really ignorant for okabe anymore
it's the opposite of what humans are
trained and bred to believe in
to be happy with nothing and i feel like
that contradiction to human character
makes the story so much more visceral
and difficult for the characters
themselves
it makes the watchers sympathize with
the characters because all of us know
that we would never want to undo
all of the gains we've made any progress
we've made in our life
it is again that appeal to humanity
steins gate has so much beneath the
surface so much that i don't think
there's honestly a cap on the amount of
videos that can be made analyzing it
just because of the extraordinary human
appeal
and hidden meanings to it if you guys
want more steins gate videos or more
deep dive videos like this in general
make sure to like and comment down below
i love making this kind of video
and i love looking deeper into shows
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future end up show manga and character
[Music]
analyses